hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and this is
unbelievable the villains just turned
the entire mha story upside down in a
matter of moments the return of kurogiri
absolutely broke the final Arc of mha
and it's too late to go back now full
power shigaraki Sad Man's parade Dobby's
nomu Powers it's all happening so let's
get into it you guys know the drill if
you enjoy our vids and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now and if you're one
of the over 50 of people who are still
not subscribed to the channel even
though you watch our videos make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing is completely
free on YouTube and it might seem like a
little thing to you but it actually
helps us out a lot finally this video
will of course contain mha manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in the previous
chapter we saw that spinner had managed
to reach kurogiri and after a botched
attempt to reach him using a recorder
spinner ultimately managed to awaken him
using the hand that shigeraki used to
wear as part of his old villain costume
as that chapter came to an end we were
left wondering whether the person who
awakens would be kurogiri or shirakumo
especially after we learned that
kurogiri now has one human looking eye
and that he has some of the speech
patterns that shirakumo used to have
well the latest chapter answers our
question very quickly will kurogiri be
conflicted about which side to choose or
will he immediately jump in to help the
villains which would of course instantly
switch the balance of power on the
battlefield on the very first page the
narrator confirms that present Mike's
voice didn't reach shirakumo the one who
is awake is kurogiri and the epic battle
between heroes and villains is about to
reach a complete new level now of course
I personally do believe that shirakumo
will awaken eventually but for now that
is not the case in my previous mha video
I warned that if kurogiri awakens and
joins the battle on the side of the
villains he would instantly change the
game completely because he can teleport
shigaraki away from the effects of
aizawa's Quirk which would allow
shigaraki to instantly regenerate and
use all of his other quirks once more
but even I didn't think that kurukiri
would create such absolute chaos in such
a short period of time he didn't just
change the game on the battlefield the
battlefield where shigaraki is currently
located but on every single Battlefield
at practically the same time but more on
that in a little bit we are then taken
to a weather forecast all the way in the
United States where new best girl
Merrell explains that a massive
flamagenitus cloud has suddenly formed
over Japan and is continuing to grow at
an alarming rate this is basically a
massive flame Cloud the kind of cloud
that forms during a huge volcanic
eruption for example and Merrill states
that if this Cloud enters the jet stream
it will influence the weather all the
way in North America and this type of
phenomenon is definitely a real thing I
remember years ago when a volcano
erupted in Iceland and flights had to be
canceled and diverted across Europe and
North America because the cloud was just
so big and the planes couldn't fly
through it it seems that this giant fire
Cloud formed as a result of multiple
enormous heat sources combining with
each other and these heat sources are
none other than the todorokis themselves
best girl Merrell then starts getting
philosophical on us and questioning
whether everything that's happening now
started with the birth of the first
Quirk user the luminescent baby did the
combination of human nature and the
appearance of quirks inevitably lead to
large-scale conflict that is now
reaching a global scale was all of this
unavoidable from day one be because
human nature is what it is and gaining
new powers just leads to more corruption
but Meryl then adds that a single
person's power can change the whole
world and it is clear that she is now
going off script this is not what she
was supposed to say and when her
co-workers ask her what she's doing she
says that the world is trying to flatter
all for one in order to appease him and
avoid conflict with him but she
disagrees with that approach as soon as
she says this the newscast cuts to
commercials typical mainstream media but
good for Merrell I honestly hope this
won't be her only appearance and that
she will return to the story because she
seems awesome and she is also very very
attractive back in Japan the heat that
is being generated by the newly
reinvigorated Dobby is absolutely
unbearable Shoto and all of endeavor
Sidekicks have already pushed themselves
beyond their limits they feel as if the
heat and Flames May consume them at any
point point and yet Toya AKA Dobby is
still standing to be fair he looks like
a charred flaming zombie he looks more
like a burning nomu than a man but he is
still standing nevertheless Dobby can
tell that his body won't be able to hold
out forever he realizes that his
original plan of first taking out Shoto
and then bringing his body as a present
for endeavor won't work because Endeavor
is located far away in gunga and Dobby's
body simply won't hold out for that long
if he wants to confront Endeavor before
he completely burns up Dobby will have
to leave Shoto behind and head out for
his father's location right now Dobby
then uses his immense Flames to launch
himself into the air and essentially fly
towards Endeavor while being propelled
by the power of his own Flames Vernon
and the other Sidekicks are shocked that
Dobby has been able to unleash such
incredible power especially since his
body was always weak to Fire and he
didn't have the kind of resistance that
endeavor and Shoto have if you guys
recall my personal theory is that Dobby
was turned into some sort of human nomu
hybrid by Dr ujiko after all for one
found him on sekoto Peak and that is why
Dobby has been able to accomplish these
seemingly impossible tasks and still
survive Shoto desperately tries to
convince Dobby to stay and fight him but
Dobby is already soaring through the air
and then suddenly as he is flying one of
kurogiri's warp gate portals shows up
and teleports Dobby to another location
back at the UA the flame Cloud that
Merrell was talking about is creating
strong gusts of wind that are tossing
debris all over the place needless to
say this is making it extremely hard for
monoma to keep his eyes open non-stop in
order to keep erasing shigaraki's quirks
but to his credit monoma refuses to quit
he knows that this is going to be a
historic battle between mean good and
evil and he wants to be remembered as
the reason why the heroes won so here we
see monoma's obnoxious Eagle actually
coming in handy for once seriously
though respect to monoma he has been an
absolute Chad during this Arc and as far
as I'm concerned all his cringy
annoyingness from the past is long
forgotten but just as monoma is psyching
himself up to keep going until the
heroes win kurogiri's portal appears
right behind him and we can already see
President Mike and shigaraki's old
costume hand coming through the portal
this portal is being generated by
kurogiri's own body we can actually see
his eyes in the upper section of the
portal so kurogiri himself is arriving
in the flesh as izawa turns around and
looks at his old friend shirakumo who is
now the villain kurogiri the chapter
takes us to gunga where Prime all for
one is still facing off against Endeavor
Hawks and a few other Heroes and hero
students all for one then explains that
he installed a chip in shigaraki's old
costume hand and this is apparently the
one that belonged to Nana shimura that
chip activated when spinner brought the
hand close to kurogiri this chip somehow
signaled the tukurogiri to wake up and
to begin obeying the orders of the
villains so again all for one had a
backup plan even though spinner brought
that voice recorder and that he couldn't
use it because it broke all for one had
anticipated that something like this
could happen and he had installed that
chip as a backup say what you will about
him but all for one truly is a
mastermind when it comes to planning and
strategizing and as reprehensible as his
actions are I can definitely appreciate
his Evil Genius although he is not one
of my favorite villains in anime manga
his Evil Genius is definitely worthy of
a final villain as all for one is
talking two black portals suddenly
appear right above Endeavor Dobby
emerges from one of them and says hey
there dad meanwhile twice appears in the
other one and calls out angrily to Hawks
Yes you heard that right I said twice
two twices or twice clones appear and
all for one proclaims that a Sad Man's
death has planted a seed of hatred in a
young girl's heart that's right this
means that kurogiri has already warped
toga from okuto Island to gunga and she
has already used twice as blood to
become twice and to activate his Quirk
to make things even darker one of the
twices seems to be holding a piece of
tsuyu's goggles the one she wears on her
head as part of her hero costume when we
last Saw to you she and ochako were
fighting toga on okuto island so this
indicates that toga definitely won that
fight and we can just hope that tsuyu
and ochako are okay and we all know what
comes next Tolga is desperate for
revenge for twice his death and she is
about to use Sad Man's parade to create
an infinite number of clones and
completely overwhelm the Heroes all for
one says that now everyone will see what
would have happened if twice had not
been taken out by hawks during the
previous war as Hawks screams out that
they have to kill twice right now this
epic chapter comes to an end and yes
just as I feared things have changed
completely within just one chapter all
thanks to kurogiri kurogiri has
completely changed the game and not just
on the main Battlefield which is the
flying UA grounds but on every
Battlefield Dobby is now suddenly in
gunga and so is toga who is already
using twice as Quirk while she was still
on okuto island the heroes were fairly
safe from Sad Man's parade well at least
the heroes who weren't also stuck on
okuto island were but now in a matter of
mere moments kurogiri has changed
everything toga and Dabi are already in
gunga kurogi himself is already at UA
and just seconds away from allowing
shigaraki to use his full power again
and things are suddenly looking
extremely bad for the heroes we went
from Deku actually getting the upper
hand on shigaraki to everything
completely collapsing on every
Battlefield in the span of a single
chapter and that's before we even take
into account that giant fire cloud and
everything else that's happening across
Japan and the world man this really does
feel like the beginning of the true
final battle in mha the real beginning
of the end at this point it's hard for
me to imagine that all the major Heroes
and hero students are going to survive
this fight with the huge advantage that
the villains just procured for
themselves by releasing kurogiri it is
very likely that we are about to see
some Heroes and hero students violently
erased from the story on top of this we
also have to remember that there seems
to be a time limit for how long Deku can
use gear shift so if his time runs out
and shigaraki regains the full use of
his quirks around the same time we're
gonna see an absolute bloodbath at UA
and yes with all for one in his prime a
completely deranged Dobby and toga using
twice as Quirk and gunga we can expect a
major bloodbath there too this is
honestly so exciting and so terrifying
at the same time on the one hand this is
going to be a freaking amazing battle or
two amazing battles that are going to be
extremely exciting to watch but on the
other hand we have to prepare ourselves
for potential deaths including the
deaths of characters we've grown to care
about like maybe monoman izawa Hawks and
so on I'm not afraid for Deku or any of
the main main characters but I just hope
that my boy Manuel makes it out alive
let's be real he's been carrying the
heroes for years and without his help
the entire hero Society would have
collapsed all long time ago but what do
you guys think are we about to see full
power shigaraki as soon as the next
chapter is toga about to unleash Sad
Man's parade on Hawks the man
responsible for killing twice are we
going to see major Heroes and hero
students die and if so which ones
definitely let me know what you think
down in the comments below I always love
hearing from you if you enjoy our mha
content and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
right now it helps us out with that
YouTube algorithm and if you're one of
the over 50 of people who watch our
videos but aren't subscribed yet do me a
big favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications
subscribing on YouTube is completely
free and it helps me out a lot you can
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at animeoproar Big thank you to all of
our anime outpro patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to trucker Tim a disciple of
Lord twigo himself and I can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons
including Alpha Sigma but they have the
toasted Qi Cory McGowan own Taylor and
Anime s kodam finally thank you to all
of our other patrons including Pro Hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
Angel Cruz Alicia Octor Fatboy games
kaido might be a duck alivenia Sandy and
the school bus if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you consider supporting us on patreon or
by becoming a channel member as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys